hello in this video we'll talk about
transposons which are dna sequences that
can move from one location in the genome
to another and that's why they are known
as jumping genes the pioneering work on
transposon came from barbara mclintock
and for her work she was recognized and
awarded the nobel prize in 1983. let us
look at how transposons work transposons
can work in two different operational
modes
in first mode they can jump from one
location in the genome
to the another location
and in this process they don't leave any
copy behind this is known as
non-replicative mode of transposition
in the second regime they can make a
copy of themselves and that copy can
jump from one location to another this
is known as replicative mode of
transposition
so
we can understand there are two modes of
transposition
first is without duplication
and the second is with duplication
you can imagine these things to be a cut
and paste and copy and paste mechanism
i know you can relate that
interesting fact is transposable
elements composes
50 percent of our genomes
but
they are generally epigenetically silent
now the question is what are the
function of these transposable elements
how they are relevant for us or our
physiology
it turns out that transposable elements
are involved in several diseases like
myocardial infarction neurodevelopmental
disorders neurodegenerative diseases and
even it has neuro it has immune
modulatory functions
that means transposable elements are
fairly important
but the question is how do they work
so let's try to understand that part in
a moment
now the jump the jumping genes can jump
from one location to another but the
biggest question is what's the big deal
about it yes there is a big deal behind
this jumping process let's say a
transposon jumps from one location in
the gene and lands inside a coding
sequence of a structural gene
that means it would disrupt that
particular gene right
now this particular gene has an open
reading frame and this open reading
frame is now disrupted due to the
integration of transposon that means
possibly the functional product of that
gene would not be obtained
there could be other consequences of
this transposition let's say a
transposon hops
and lands into a regulatory sequence
inside a genome
now this regulatory sequence controls
the transcription right so obviously
after integration into a regulatory
sequence
it can positively or let's say
negatively regulate gene expression from
a nearby gene so obviously transposon
has activity on
on gene expression as well so let's
summarize this part
transposon can show mutagenic effect
they can get inserted into a location
and disrupt a gene
they could silence
nearby genes by attracting epigenetic
modifiers
transposons can also act as a source of
long non-coding rna and thereby they
have great regulatory roles
and lastly they can act as enhancer or
repressor and thereby controls gene
expression as well
now let's talk about the classification
of transposons at least the overview of
it transposons can be divided into three
broad classes dna transposons virus-like
retrotransposons and poly-a
retrotransposons each of them has their
distinct features let's talk about dna
transposon first which has a particular
region known as transposes coding region
which codes for the transposes enzyme
now
apart from that the other feature is the
terminal inverted repeats which is
recognized by the transposes so let's
see how they work
so the transposes enzyme
recognize the inverted repeats in the
terminals and they cleave the dna and
creates a double-stranded dna break
now these transposable element can be
integrated to a new region in the genome
and thereby it can jump from one
location to another
so this is how the integration works
now let's talk about the virus like
retrotransposons
these has inverted terminal repeats as
usual but at the same time it has two
genes encoding for reverse transcriptase
and
integrase
and both of these are important for the
function of virus like retrotransposon
let us try to understand that
so let's try to understand how virus
like retro transposons get integrated
into the genome
so first
the transposon would be transcribed
and reverse transcriptase would make a
copy of that and forming a cdna-like
structure
so this cdna
or the cdna intermediate would be
integrated into a new location with the
help of the enzyme in degrees and
thereby
the virus like retrotransposons get
into a new genomic location
let's talk about poly a retrotransposons
which exactly look like a gene why is so
let me tell you
so these retrotransposons differ from
other classes of transposons by not
having the inverted terminal repeats
they have five prime and three prime utr
just like our mrnas
they also have two orfs or f1 and two
and lastly they have a at rich region
which mimics the polyetail of an mrna
so they pretty much look like a gene
now the orf1 encodes
for a rna binding protein and orf2
encodes
for a protein which has endonuclease and
reverse transcriptase activity
now exactly how it why the how poly a
like retrotransposon work it's beyond
the scope of this overview video in a
different video i will be discussing how
these particular retrotransposons work
now let us try to understand
more applications of these transpose
transposons transposons are really
important in the field of molecular
biology especially the recombinant dna
technology let's say you want to create
a stable transgenic cell line so
obviously your transgenic construct need
to be integrated into the genome and
that is done by piggyback vectors which
are actually transposon based vectors
so this piggyback vector along with the
transposes enzyme is injected into the
cell and the cargo is integrated with
the help of transposition mechanism and
this integration is fairly stable
so obviously let's say this cargo is a
gfp so you can create a cell line which
is stably expressing gfp
now principles of transposition is
nowadays used in atac sequencing or
attack sequencing
and this particular sequencing technique
is used to study chromatin accessibility
so especially in terms of molecular
biology the principles of transposition
is fairly important
now let us quickly summarize what we
have learned so far we have learned what
are transposons how do they work
what why transposons are important their
implication in disease and biomedical
sciences
and lastly we also learned about
different classes of transposition
transposons so this was a overview video
in subsequent video we'll delve into
deep of all of these uh transposon
classes and how they function their
examples and their relevance
thanks for watching if you like this
video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe thank
you